speaking of blm this is from the courier
journal says a racial justice protest
outside the kentucky international
convention center over the weekend
has drawn criticism from some community
members who say demonstrators should not
have targeted children entering a cheer
competition
well some community members say that
some communities
members are saying maybe you don't
target kids
some and then of course there are plenty
on the pro
targeting kids side uh it says for
several hours saturday a group of about
30 protesters walked around outside the
downtown building chanting into
megaphones and calling on sparkly
dressed kids to recognize their white
privilege
video from the scene has ignited anger
on social media from residents who say
that city
officials should do more to crack down
on protests that have disrupted
louisville's
streets and sidewalks for more than nine
months we have
some of that video let's let's watch
some of it now
[Music]
[Applause]
do something blue today with your white
privilege besides cheer
the reason why you get to be here in
these pretty gorgeous houses with your
torch there you go
black mothers are burying their babies
or white brothers and their children to
care competition
do something blessed today thank you
yeah this this is mental illness you
know
that that the response when you've got a
woman screaming into a megaphone
at little kids walking down the street
that's a mentally ill woman she should
be put in a mental asylum
that that's what we need to do with
someone like that
screaming at her about brianna taylor
what the hell are these kids have to do
with brianna taylor
brianna taylor was um
uh was was shot by police accidentally
and so therefore that means that these
little kids can't go to a cheer
competition
connect those dots for me i'd like to
hear you well you can't because you're
insane you're you're a lunatic
if you couldn't understand what you were
saying into the megaphone and this was
if you're what if you're listening to
the audio podcast these were
like little girls in their cheer outfits
go no chair competition walking down the
street
and then you've got these blm scumbags
screaming at them
what do these kids do nothing they're
just kids
it sounded like she said do something
black today with your white privilege
besides cheer and then she also said uh
the reason that you're
that you're able to to participate into
your competition is because of your
white privilege
really so there are no black
cheerleaders huh that's this is a
white thing cheerleading is a reflection
of uh white privilege so you're telling
me
that's i'm not gonna find any if if if
you were to go into that cheer
competition you're telling me there
wouldn't be
plenty of black cheerleaders there too
really
yeah i was saying before if you're on
the side
where cities have to shut down and board
up shop
because they're afraid that they're
gonna make you mad that's an indication
that you're
on the wrong side that you're the bad
guy
well here's another good hint if you're
on the side that does
that kind of thing and it's not like
this is some sort of
unique occurrence this is one of blm's
favorite tactics just walking down the
street
harassing completely innocent random
people or simply trying to go about
their day
including kids so if you're on the side
that does that that should tell you
something
you're the bad guy listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated